[Music]
put afternoon business welcome to our
talk to the program and now we hear this
special guest information at the State
Hospital thank you man - my name is
decision cooler I am here to tell our
people we are going to have an i camp
Natasha cot a state hospital we are here
to invite all the other people or
everybody who is at home that is not
seen to come and see us at the eye
clinic so we are doing all of our
listener that we have got one month for
you to come to the hospital for your
screening to be operated during our I
camp if you are seeing a person around
you who is not seen please bring them to
the hospital
bring your uncle bring your grandmother
bring everybody to come this is your
chance to see a king
my name is dr. Helen Indomie I do have a
vehicle name it is traditional name
which is Sunday Pavano it means I am
better off I was born during the
apartheid system where the education was
different for the black people and white
people where young people were
demonstrating and scared to be arrested
to be put in prison they decide to leave
the country we left the country with
three of my friends and we may need to
sneak over the border into an world in
Angola there was civil war bombings and
killings camps being attacked in the
middle of the night while we are
sleeping while hearing bullets flying
all over your head copses all over the
place and managing our 15 years old
[Music]
we cross into Zambia I ended up in the
refugee camps where we build hospitals
and built our own schools
we built our parents where we were going
to stay and we started going to school
then we have magnetic history geography
English and all that it was completely
eye-opening I ended up went to
university in Leipzig Germany to start
medicine when independence came to
Namibia I came back home I started my
internship I was the only opthamologist
working for the state you have to know
that button then it is a belief that
when you are already go blind and that
is God's willing nothing can be done
about it
when I started the I cans just 82
patient came because they say if you go
there that young girl is going to
destroy your eyes but then the 82 that
we operated on spread the message like
wildfire the following year we couldn't
control the crowd they came in there
thousand everybody now wanted to be
operated on they stand up independence
and really come we have doctors and now
we can see you cannot just be in the
private practice making money knowing
very well there are thousands who are
blind and they need help and you cannot
call yourself a developed country if you
have people getting blind from cataracts
day
[Music]
no money in this world can pay for the
happiness of someone who was blind and
suddenly we take of that iPad then they
said doctor I can see
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
if I have to tell you the study that
they tell you after they regain their
sight we'll spend the whole night here
doctor now that I can see I'm going to
wake hat and plow a lot of food doctor
now that I can see I'm going to see my
grandchildren that a heaven seen for
five six years
or a mother who have given birth and she
never saw her baby came to see the child
after cataract surgery
[Music]
all of us went through difficult times
during the liberation struggle in the
refugee camps and that is also what
connected us together that we must go
back and help just like we were helped
we have to have a culture of giving back
to less fortunate people so that they
can also be transformed
just like ours transformed
[Music]
[Music]
you
you